the former prime minister gordon brown i
asked given that scotland seems to have
one foot already out the door
is it going to take the full step
no i don't think so i think if there was
a referendum we'd win it
and scotland would stay in the united
kingdom but it's going to be a hard
battle
because people are frustrated they're
fed up not just in scotland
but in the regions of england in wales
and i see a sense growing right across
the whole of the united kingdom that
people feel
in the regions and the nations they're
not being listened to they're not being
consulted
westminster whitehall is out of touch
and that's why i think we've got to say
that at the end of this covered crisis
we're going to review at the way we
govern ourselves the way we manage
affairs
whether it's public health or whether
how we manage the economy recession
industry employment and i think we're
going to have to get a far better
balance between the powers that the
nations and regions hold
and i'm talking about the areas around
manchester liverpool newcastle bristol
london of course all the different parts
of the united kingdom they need far more
powers of economic initiative
and the centre will have to admit that
it cannot do everything itself and that
centralization is not working
in the way that it could you clearly
want more
devolution more powers to the region and
boris johnson reportedly said there
recently in a zoom call with
conservative mps
that devolution has been a disaster do
you think he's right
well he's completely out of touch and
and that's why he is not
popular in scotland but neither would he
be popular in wales where people
want devolution to work and you can see
from andy burnham in
manchester steve rutherman liverpool
jamie driscoll the mayor of newcastle
marvin in bristol sadiq khan in london
that they're all saying
and sheffield of course with dan jarvis
they're all saying they need more power
to be able to make decisions closer to
home and there's something quite wrong
about the british constitution now
that we have a multinational state we
have regions with a great deal of
different needs and different traditions
and different cultures and different
desires
but this government has not found a way
of cooperating with them of consulting
them of working with them
and there seems to be no formal
mechanisms in place by which the mayors
or the first ministers
can actually talk to the prime minister
or talk to the leading cabinet ministers
and this really matters because we
failed on test and track as far as i can
see
we were too slow on testing there's a
huge standoff about the local lockdowns
we've got a huge issue coming up on
vaccination where
it's great what the scientists have done
but unless we have local systems of
delivery that are coordinated
with the training of people and the
supply and of course the
the logistics to get supplies there then
that vaccination thing will not work the
way it should and it's a huge task ahead
of us
and so the british way of governing has
got to change if we're going to meet the
needs and aspirations of people
in all parts of the country at the same
time though
is there an argument that further
devolution does
put you further along the path to
independence you wrote to the new
statements when recently
it was naive to think we could create
strong scottish welsh
northern irish and regional
decision-making bodies
and automatically expect people to feel
more british as a result
equally it was naive not to anticipate
that devolution
could create a megaphone for
intensifying resentment
so do you think the last labour
government wasn't
well the word there is automatic we
should not have expected that
automatically everything would be okay
you've got to build
systems where you cooperate between the
different administrations
where there's some form of coordination
and collaboration
where people are prepared to work
together and that clearly has not
happened we tried it to be fair to what
we were trying to do
i wanted joint ministerial committees
and everything else to work
but this is not working they have not
been met meeting under the conservative
government other than on that brexit
and and you can talk to every mayor and
they will say and conservative ones will
say as well as labor ones
that they do not feel that they are let
into the discussions that matter to
their own areas
and therefore we fall down and you
mentioned at the beginning of the
interview
that if there was another referendum on
scottish independence that you think the
campaign
to stay in the union would win at the
same time though polls
are showing now a majority for
independence and if the snp do win a
majority
at next year's holyrood elections do you
think they'll have a mandate for another
referendum
i don't think people want to referendum
now and i the question is
whether you should have a referendum you
could of course have a referendum if you
wanted to
but should you have a referendum and the
answer is
no i don't think you should have a
referendum at this stage
sorry we're dealing with yeah but look
an election in may
the snp want a referendum 2021
we've got to deal with the recession
unemployment is rising
we've got to vaccinate people in
scotland and perhaps a second round we
don't know whether there's going to be a
third or fourth wave of this disease
and the idea you can have a referendum
during the first
12 months of the next year seems to me
quite unrealistic
and is a sign that the nationalists are
really out of touch with the priorities
of the scottish people
i wonder how much you think the
personalities come into it as well
there's
a hundred point difference between
nicola sturgeon's approval ratings in
scotland and boris johnson's hers as
plus 49
his is minus 57. if boris johnson
is the face of the campaign to stay
you're going to lose aren't you
i think boris johnson has got to do
something
to show that he cares about scotland but
he's also going to do it for wales
and he's also going to do it for the
regions of england where quite frankly
some of his statements have gone down
badly badly as well you know as a prime
minister
and i found this you've got to spend
time bringing people together
in the end it's you the prime minister
that's got to try to unite the country
you can't rely
on different parts of the country coming
together automatically
you've got to bring people together and
he has no forum in which he consults the
people who are making decisions about
this
virus in the regions at no permanent
forum
there is no constitutional working
relationship that is actually
operational between him and scotland
wales and northern ireland
and he's really got to think about that
and i don't want it to be an issue of
personalities
i want it to be about how we approach
the future of the united kingdom because
people are really fed up a lot of people
feel that they are treated as
second-class
citizens they feel that some of the
decisions over the lockdowns were made
without taking into account the needs of
the north in particular
and i really think we've got to face up
to this you know as a prime minister
you've also got to be two steps ahead of
events
and this is an issue that's coming down
the tracks yes we've got to get
vaccination out there and i do applaud
the scientists that have made this
possible
yes we've got to get the economy back
working again but to do these things
properly in the future to manage public
health and to manage the economy better
we've got to have a better way of
working together we've got to have a
better way of showing that
joint working can bring better results
yeah absolutely critical as you said
in that fight against covid um i'm keen
to get your
opinion on brexit too because it does
feel as if those talks are reaching
an absolutely critical phase uh this
weekend if boris johnson does come back
with a trade deal
should labour back it
this is very interesting by the way
because he always takes it to the last
minute
and he's always hoping that angela
merkel or someone
will step in so the irish tea shop
stepped in the last time and they made a
deal
i think he's hoping that angela merkel
who's really chairing the european
council
next thursday is going to step in and i
don't think you can say what you do
about the deal until you know what the
deal is
but what's actually happening is if
there is no deal now
i see huge international implications
from what he fails to deliver
because we would be in an economic war
with europe that would cost us
very dearly food drugs and everything
else we'd find it difficult to get into
the country without tariffs and without
holdups but we'd also be in an economic
war with america because there'd be no
chance of a trade treaty with america
and so boris johnson is going to end up
as the most
isolated prime minister in peacetime
history
with no friends around the world because
he has
simply chosen a path of confrontation
when everybody knows
that it's in britain's economic interest
maybe not in the
brexiteers ideological interests but
it's in britain's economic interest
to get a deal and to get a deal now so
hang on a minute though
if you're saying that no deal would put
us in an economic war with europe
and an economic war with america surely
you think that labour should back a
trade deal
well that's up to pierre starman to make
his decision but i would make my
decision and i don't think he's going to
make his decision until he sees what the
deal is
one of the problems that we've got
sophie
hold on one of the problems we got is
the difference between a no deal and a
deal
is becoming quite slim because the deal
that i see coming forward
and i you know i i want us to be in
an economic relationship with europe and
therefore i want a deal at this stage
but the deal that is coming forward is
quite a difficult one though
because most of the big questions about
state aids and about
what would happen if britain didn't
follow the level playing field
most of these questions may yet be
unresolved by the deal
it looks as if what's going to happen is
they're going to say yes we'll have tara
free trade we'll have quota free trade
but the minute you breach the level
playing field that we want to see happen
we are
reserving the right to impose tariffs
and impose
sanctions upon you and so you may have
an unstable relationship over the next
few months or even indeed over the next
few years because all they can get to in
this negotiation is a minimalist
deal which leaves people very uncertain
about the path of the economy
the chancellor has certainly got his
work cut out trying to negotiate the
economic impact of brexit and of course
as well the
economic crisis of covid at the same
time rishi sunak is one of the few
politicians who seems to have his
approval ratings intact some people say
he's got his eye on the top job
what advice would you give to a
chancellor who
might have his eye on moving from number
11 to number 10.
well you know i used to say when i was
the chancellor there was only two kinds
of chancellor
there were those who failed and those
who got out just in time
and if i were richie sunic i would think
that uh having given out all this money
uh his problems are really now beginning
and i think he's going to be tested and
i think he
i supported what he did in march and a
lot of us did i think he's
not done well in the last two months
with the measures he's taken they've
been
i think we've had five budget statements
and he has not provided for the recovery
in the way that
should be done and i think he faces huge
problems in the future and that will
decide his fate
is whether he's a good chancellor or not
not whether he wants to be prime
minister or not
and i think that he's making some
mistakes now that he should rectify
and i fear a number of things very high
unemployment
i think there's a million young people
who are not working at the moment and
that's a tragedy
for future generations that they cannot
get the chance
to show that they've got a skill and get
a job i suspect there are hundreds of
thousands of businesses that are just
being kept alive by loans
but they don't have the economic
activity that can guarantee the the
future
and you need to underpin the economy by
greater strength
from the treasury and from the bank of
england than i think is being provided
at the moment so
he has got his work cut out and he must
plan a recovery
and not rest on his laurels because
we've had a
rescue operation we need a recovery
operation now
and i don't think that is forthcoming
yet from the government